the very design of the house of commons
chamber is adversarial and we have had
weeks of angry confrontations over the
pm's behavior his character and his
fitness to lead but today the atmosphere
shifted because the main parties now
have a common enemy
putin has invaded a sovereign european
nation
it does have my support and if it's used
we will support it
but labour want boris johnson to go
further with sanctions and military
support which is why the prime minister
preempted some of that with this the uk
will shortly be providing a further
package of military support to ukraine
now sakia's advisers say they chose to
ask questions on sanctions because they
know many back bench story mps want
tougher action the labour leader is also
keen to show his party is strong on
defense and security in contrast with
criticisms of his predecessor jeremy
corbyn and to prove that very point i
spotted the defense secretary ben
wallace and his labour shadow are john
healey standing side by side next to the
speaker's chair and leaving the chamber
together
and there were moments when boris
johnson praised the man who spent weeks
attacking him
and i'm grateful by the way uh for the
general support uh that the opposition
have given and mr speaker i'm genuinely
grateful uh for the tone of his last
question
but a small group of left-wing labour
mps are critical of nato and what they
argue is the organization's eastwood
expansion boris johnson made sure to
exploit that split
uh something that would be strong mr
speaker would be to take the whip away
from the 14 members of the labour party
who
who say that the aggressor in ukraine is
nato that would be that would be a
strong thing to do
well our analysis of kierstama's
language today shows one of the words he
used most was support which you can see
right here that in itself is pretty rare
but the labour leader was not completely
supportive and questioned the
conservative party's record of receiving
donations from individuals with links to
russia the flood of foreign money
drowning our politics
we can all now see how serious this is
the largest single corporate donation uh
to the labour party came from a member
of the chinese communist party at this
moment as the house agreed yesterday we
have to stand united
[Applause]
sky news analysis of boris johnson's
language today shows his change in tone
in particular the pm as you can see here
stressed how grateful he was for
opposition to support the word together
also coming up
political parties working together as
well as western nations and in another
old pmq's trick mr johnson has clearly
been anticipating questions about the uk
broadcasting license of the
kremlin-backed tv channel rt formerly
russia today and so was primed to say
this
my right honourable friend the secretary
of state for culture media sport has
already
asked ofcom to review uh that matter and
as soon as the smp's westminster leader
ian blackford stood up there were shouts
and jeers from the tory benches
including from the culture secretary
nadine doris who had earlier been
sharing a pack of polos with fellow
heckler michael gove the reason for that
heckle alex salmond scotland's first
minister for seven years and the snp's
leader for 20 who has now left the party
and presents a show on the controversial
tv channel
join me every thursday on the alex
salmon show coming from somebody uh
whose very own alex salmond is a leading
a leading presenter a leading presenter
on as far as i know on russia today well
whatever happens next in ukraine defense
and security are sure to feature more
regularly at pmqs in the coming days
expect further pressure on both the
conservatives and labour parties about
questionable political donations and on
the government as calls for tougher
action on russia get louder